so the bad news will just not stop
coming for donald trump a bombshell new
york times article this week yesterday
in fact
revealing that donald trump has an
undisclosed bank account
in china and it exposes a whole series
of chinese business pursuits this is of
course the same
donald trump that has been going after
china
for the virus and going after china for
doing this and that unfair thing to the
united states the same donald trump that
has been repeating for months that if
joe biden were to be president china
would control
biden the same trump whose republican
party has been going after
joe biden's son hunter biden for opening
a bank account
in china that donald trump has a bank
account
in china and a long history of trying to
do business with china the new york
times has continued to analyze the tax
records that were the basis for the
blockbuster story
about trump paying no federal taxes in
10 of the last 15 years from a few weeks
ago
which feels like years ago by the way
that story was just a few weeks ago
and the new york times has now learned
that donald trump has bank accounts in
britain
in ireland and yes in china the chinese
bank account shocker
was not on donald trump's public
financial disclosures because it's held
under
a convenient corporate name and that
chinese bank account paid 188
000 in taxes to the chinese government
between 2013 and 2015. understand that
that means
trump's business paid more tax to the
chinese government in those years
than trump paid in the united states
federally and donald trump
is saying biden has the china problem
and
we know that trump projects all the time
trump accuses others of being corrupt
when he's corrupt
trump accuses others of nepotism when
he's the king of nepotism
trump accuses others of receiving
softball interviews
when he gets weekly softball interviews
from fox and friends and sean hannity
and maria bartiromo and eric bowling
yesterday and the whole cast at fox news
but this is another level of projection
with china claiming for weeks now
that hunter biden has this and that
financial connection to china
and it's a problem for joe biden and so
on
and all along donald trump has had an
undisclosed chinese bank account
and this puts a huge list of actions
related to china
under the microscope once again many
chinese government proposals
came after trump became president ivanka
trump
won chinese trademark approvals
for her was it clothing or handbags
after she joined the white house staff
and
on and on and on and all of these now
need to be scrutinized under a new light
not that they didn't need to be
scrutinized before it's
a perfect amalgam of possible
nepotism cronyism and corruption
which i don't think we will ever know
the full scope of i know there's this
idea
that after trump leaves whether it's in
in you know a few months or in four
years
there will be investigations and we'll
eventually get to the bottom of it i
don't think we will
and let me just give you one more
example and again
each one of these examples could be a
huge story
a major investigation by itself and i
assure you
if this was a story about chelsea
clinton during a hillary presidency
instead of about ivanka it would be a
huge story
this from the same new york times
investigation
says quote not long after winning the
2016 election mr trump reported selling
a penthouse
in one of his manhattan buildings for
15.8 million dollars
to a chinese-american businesswoman
named xiaoyan
chen who bought the unit previously
occupied by ivanka trump and her husband
jared kushner
in an off-market transaction ms chen
runs an international consulting firm
and reportedly has high level
connections to government and political
elites in china
circumstantially that is as
much of a red flag or more ripe for
investigation
than anything that we have about hunter
biden and joe biden right now
by itself that sale could be
a huge story to investigate but again we
may never know the full scope of what's
gone down and what favors have been
offered and done
in exchange for what one of you emailed
me about this story
saying what is the breaking point for
trump supporters and for republicans
with this stuff republican congressmen
all know
trump may be tied to all of these
different countries and
what's the breaking point the answer is
we're 13 days away from the election
there is no breaking point if trump wins
they win
in a sense and they just try to maintain
power if trump loses
they start to distance themselves from
trump pretend they never really
supported him he wasn't really a
republican
and move on and you could apply that
prediction
not just to republican elected officials
but just your average run-of-the-mill
trump supporter and we will see
what the new york times has in the next
13 days based on these documents
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over sixty
thousand masks to health care
institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over a hundred and
fifty dollars you can get there by going
to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david